Hello there!
Did you really believe
that “Attention is all you need”?
According to the papers of the last weeks,
not anymore.
In today’s video, we showcase the FNet paper
replacing the self-attention (in BERT) with
Fourier Transforms!
"Foururorie", what?
Ms. Coffee Bean, did you know it all along
that self-attention is doomed?
Then why did'nt you tell me?
Is it because I left you in the coffee roaster
for such a long time?
Here we go:
The FNet, proposed in this paper, does one
modification to the transfomer architecture,
but this one thing has quite the impact.
For a bit of context here:
The Transformer -- composed of self-attention,
followed by fully-connected layers and not
to forget about the residual connections and
layer normalization -- had been proven to
be extremely successful on multiple data modalities:
It started with text, became mainstream on
both image and text, then on image only (watch
Ms. Coffee Bean’s videos for all of this),
then it moved on to speech and even further
than that.
But powerful as it is, the Transformer has
a problem:
The self-attention mechanism scales quadratically
in time and memory with increasing sequence
length.
In other words, there is a limit to what the
length of your text might be.
For images, the size or resolution also determines
the sequence length and with usual transformers
you can reach the sequence length limit quite
fast.
So far, methods to reduce this quadratically
scaling attention to a linearly scaling operation
have left the concept of attention untouched:
methods like Linformer, Performer, and others,
have cleverly approximated self-attention
matrices, sped up computations and enabled
much longer sequences; but the concept of
attention stayed mostly as it was.
Well, so far...!
Because now heretic papers are coming out
and rebel against attention, "no, it’s not
attention that we need anymore!".
Ms. Coffee Bean, is machine learning now a
teenager and doesn't want attention anymore?
Because this is exactly what FNet also does:
it replaces the self-attention layers through
Fourier Transforms.
But the most important question here is:
How dare the authors make such a move and
not call their paper “Fourier is all you
need”?
The audacity of these authors is unbelievable
… Sarcasm ...
Ok, so let’s see how this replacement of
attention works and what it brings.
The FNet authors take the classical Transformer
block and modify it by replacing the self-attention
layer containing learnable parameters,
with an unparameterized, thus not a learnt
transformation, being the Fourier Transform.
So before, for each token, self-attention
layers were learning to compute importance
scores for the token given all other tokens.
So to emphasize, the computation of the importance
is learnt from data,
is task-specific and the new representation
for each token was the sum of all tokens weighted
by their importance to the original token.
Now with the Fourier Transform, the new representation
for a token is not learnt, but it is a predefined
mixing scheme of tokens.
This makes this whole thing faster, because
this layer doesn’t perform any gradient
updates, but is also unchanged from task to
task or one training scenario to another.
The mixing scheme of the tokens is following
the rules of the Fourier Transformation.
Now, what exactly is this?
This is where the math gets a little complicated
but it does not need to scare you: Here it
is just written that each token is multiplied
by sines and cosines, because this e to the
power of something, we can write as a superposition
of sines and cosines, handwavy like this.
So for example the first token is a weighted
sum of all other tokens but here the weights
are modulated by sines and cosines.
But because we are at the first token where
k equals zero, the frequency of the sines
and cosines -- hidden in this exponential
-- is zero, so the first token is just a sum
of all other tokens.
For the second token, the modulation is more
interesting by superimposing waves that increase
in frequency as we add more tokens.
For the third token, the frequency of each
wave we add increases even more, like this.
To put it as an analogy, the new representation
of each token is like a cake, where the base
(frequency) is still the first token, then
the second token adds some detail and becomes
the creme on the cake,
then the third token becomes the even more
detailed icing,
the fourth token is the super-detailed nuts,
and so on
and then the whole cake is the new token representation,
because we take the summation of all of this.
And to be fair, all of this has a real and
a complex components, but forget about it,
because after all the operations are computed,
the authors delete the imaginary component.
Anyway, the important messages here are: Firstly,
the Fourier Transform applied to tokens mixes
the tokens among themselves.
It's kind of similar to what self-attention
does but self-attention learned the weights
by which these things need to be mixed.
Also, the same thing is done to the hidden
dimensions, so that the features of the tokens
are also mixed among each other.
And until here the transformation that was
done is reversible by the inverse Fourier
Transform.
In other words,
the components of the cake can be recovered
by decomposing after each frequency.
It is the next step, the feed-forward layers
that mix things even more and usually not
in an invertible way.
The second important message is that the mixing
scheme or pattern is not learnt, it is fixed
and always follows the same rule, making the
architecture simpler and easier to compute.
It decreases the number of the learnable parameters
of the Transfomer which now is technically
FNet and not the Transformer...
Thirdly, a more advanced take home message
also mentioned in the paper, which Ms.Coffee
Bean found super-interesting, is the following:
You maybe know, or just take Ms. Coffee Bean’s
word for it, convolutions in the real/time
domain correspond to simple multiplications
in the Fourier/frequency domain.
So the first Fourier layer of the architecture
moves the representation from the real domain
to the Fourier domain and multiplications
in these layers happening afterwards, are
now actually convolutions in the real space.
So by adding
more and more Transformer layers, each one
with one Fourier layer, FNet is jumping back
and forth from multiplications to convolutions.
In other words, convolutions are somehow here
and perhaps now are taking revenge on the
Transformers and crash their party!
Are convolutions all you need??
I actually cannot hear “all you need”
anymore, but Ms. Coffee Bean makes me say
it..
Ok but one question remains: Why exactly the
Fourier Transform, you might wonder?
Reading the paper, it becomes clear that the
first thing the authors tried was simple linear
mixing schemes,
but then went for something more structured
like the Fourier Transform.
But believe it or not, the other paper getting
rid of attention, the MLP-Mixer
learns mixing patterns that look very much
like…
Fourier!
Just look, here is the base frequency, here
is the double of that frequency with its negative
counterpart.
The MLP-Mixer, found something like the Fourier
scheme on itself, but on images!
FNet has been applied to text and has the
Fourier transformation hard-coded and it seems
to work also well.
So, the FNet basically is a BERT variant without
attention but Fourier Transformations and
achieves 92% of the accuracy of BERT on GLUE
(an important NLU benchmark), which is not
exactly 100% of BERT, but good enough.
And especially because there is no quadratically
scaling attention anymore, it runs seven times
faster on GPU and two times faster on TPUs
and you can increase the sequence length!
So self-attention was praised as being the
recipe to success for quite a while, but now
papers like FNet, MLP-Mixer and gMLP relativize
this by a bit, showing that if there is enough
data and compute, the architecture does not
matter much.
So it seems like back in the days when MLPs
were a thing, we discarded MLPs too early
when perhaps the only thing that was missing
then was the data and compute scale we have
now, so we preferred CNNs or RNNs because
of their inductive biases (always a good idea
with little data).
But to say this is very unfair because architectures
like FNet or MLP-Mixer are not exactly like
a vanilla MLP from back then; the structure
of these MLPs follows the trend set by Transformers,
so Ms. Coffee Bean sees this as an evolution
and not really as a backwards... involution
or something.
In any case, now that we have seen that long
sequences are not such of a problem anymore
and that image token mixing and text token
mixing looks quite similar, Ms. Coffee Bean
thinks it's great news for multimodality where
the goal is to combine many types of input
data, that potentially comes in very long
sequences.
Especially if you append one modality to another,
like Vision & Language Transformers do.
The FNet paper is very well-written, so what
are you waiting for?
Leave a like, subscribe, share Ms. Coffee
Bean to send her around the world and go read
the paper yourself!
Okay bye!
Ms. Coffee Bean, it has been a while since
your last video, are you getting lazy or what?
Oh...!
Yes, I know I put you in the coffee roaster
and left you there, but I was busy with moving
and with a paper.
No, no!
I did not waste my time.
No, Ms. Coffee Bean that’s rude to say!
Go to your coffee roaster!
Okay bye!